aha welcome to this video playing haga
and I've got white yeah that is very
rare he always plays 11 b 3 and it's
rare that i have white I always have
black against time we'd have to play be
34 the one billionth time ok after g6 I
don't want to play g3 actually that was
a bit weird and there then the wrong set
up that's really the wrong set up ok I
thought a 6b 6b five but it doesn't want
to do that seems I'm ready for this f5
business so this is not a big deal
I wonder ever can try and I'd be high
and maybe let's try that it's not really
great but maybe he captures which is a
big mistake strategically Queen u7 I
thought maybe 85 yeah Mac come on e5
it's interesting yeah I was playing a
little bit on bishop tsp 5 which is a
bit embarrassing to play for this kind
of trap but mm-hmm but that's not a bad
result
okay so he wants to play some kind of f5
I mean I can't even do g4 yeah there's
nothing wrong with that now he may be
what of this will sacrifice a pawn
that's not correct but maybe neither
form and nope doesn't do it so here
Bishop texture form might be a move in
some cases so okay I'm playing it that
is a very stodgy move but still yeah
what are you doing when the bee farm
that's a good question not much because
the nighttime before it doesn't have any
square okay um so five now is maybe
coming
maybe have to all night eh laughter aw
to attack the a cig spawn yeah f3 that
was the move I didn't like to play but I
felt it was necessary going the eight
regrouping to d3 here is that bishop
yeah he wants to play Bishop age 6 if I
go Bishop g5 he has Bishop age 6 Bishop
h4 Bishop d2
and interesting
should you five bishop age 6 I really
have no great move then be sure the
interestings now ok I have to regroup
him for Bishop see to end and possibly
be three it's not ideal or anything but
what can you do
yeah I don't have a great bishop down c2
but it really is not such a big deal if
I get in b3 my rooks will be mobile
again and I can try other things yeah he
wants to go to f7 ng5 interesting IDM
I have some play ends the f porn so it's
not particularly clear so it's 93 a move
here high margins is what I want to play
we gave true coming I don't think
naughty tree that 93 is doing much and
so let's do it you know 93 I can take f6
salad was lucky I didn't see that before
I nah mean so let's check is there
anything that I can do here
don't really see in a particular idea
neide f1 Knight f3 maybe this is an idea
Nazi one out of three to attack d 6 that
is interesting
behind me and all the check if we called
stuff I will take it cakes I whoops you
for no my pawn will start to move king
of six mmm mmm yeah I'm okay
write a five to six million not sure
this is done doing anything
I am probably not much but he's spending
lots of time check check black forfeits
on time Joe I don't know that was tellin
ya very complicated position I mean if
he pees okay yeah he's really okay ya
know this this business oh the computers
gives before ah wow that's a strong move
and now i understand it i really didn't
understand this position I mean no the
thing is I did I did understand
something I mean this is clear after
that he has to do this and here the
queen is just unprotected and B form is
protecting the Queen from the side wow
that's very strong yeah if he takes us
now then I'm just winning this this
piece now yeah he queen is trapped and
he has to do this and I'm a piece up
that's very nice so that means he has no
move here no really decent move as I'm
threatening to take this is the best
move according to the engine after which
I take cake yeah this is fantastic for
wine are those points now we're very
weekend let's tons better than the game
the computer says winning yeah but you
have to be precise so you can screw
things up but white is much better
that's a very strong move now I didn't
see that on not at all I took some time
here more than a minute yeah but I
didn't think of before that's very very
bad at the end I was thinking okay yeah
I'm going for this kind of position here
exactly this and I was thinking okay I'm
I'm okay but it's it's not more each
five nose was good okay now and
estimated that move ok this one yeah I
actually thought this would be about
equal engine gives black Ackley edge so
what could you have done h5 again I
totally did not registered how register
how strong that is h 5 I cannot take
because of 83 h5 again was possible that
here maybe Queen g3 check I super
complicated night new one yeah the
computer says I'm better but really I
don't know look I are which was a good
move for rugby 60 that's an interesting
one I didn't see that one didn't see it
i only had 25 seconds what did i do
actually this one yeah my idea was to
bring that night over which is assessed
as equal funny enough geforce equal and
this is also equal it seems check
check you went here kingi fire okay
kingi there was just no time at all he
can take you for this fine ok 7x to a
draw but very tough game very difficult
to make heads or tails off ok well
thanks for watching